CHINA'S NATIONA
INCREASINGLY LIKVI
ITS STORY, HIGHTG MOSCOW'SPERATN
GRIEVANCESYIS N ALLIES WITRUSS O
THE BATTLEFIELD.
TH RMENTIOTH
RESISTND GROWING TORE.
PUBLICBE ITS
IMCO INDICATING ITS LL
A MEDIATOR.
CNMBING H CHINTV
CK ALONG WH SAS OF CI MOUTLETS.
OUR ?S LARGRUSSIA'S TNG POINTS,L
ATE ITS VERSION OF THE  WAR TLL.
>> Reporter: THE CHINESE FOREIGN
MINISTRY HAS YET TO RESPOUT FOR.
SSN T VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S LAST TO CHINA.
FOLLOWING THE MEETINN
PUTIN AND XI JINPING, THE TWO
GOVERNMENTS DECLARED
PARTNERSHIP WITH N.D IA'S CLOSEE
KREMLIN'S DISINFORMATIONHAS DRA
CAMPAIGN.26th AFTER
NIGHTS OF RUSSBOMBAREN
HIMSELF ON THE SF KYIVCIAL
ALLEGE ZELENSKYY H
THE COUNTRO WA
PRERECORDED.
TES, CCTV
FLASHED  CLAIMING HAS LEFT KYIV.
MORE THAN 160 CHINESE STATE
MEDIA OUTLETS PO A HASH,A SAYS L
0 MILLION VIEWS ON CHINESE NOT
DAMNING, ANNTL MEMO
FROM BEIJING NEWSU
RUSSIAVAN STARD.BEFOHE
THE MEMO DTEF NO
BLYTHING NEGATIVE ABOUT PRO-WES.
IT MISTAKENLY POSTED ON THE
'S SOCIAL MEDIEING SET TPR
EVENAL
CNN RESEARCH TT S MAJOR STATE MI
OUTLETAPPEAR TO BEOLLOWITHAT PLO
PRO-RUSSIA PARED TO
LESS5%
UGHLY 35OF POSTS
INCLUDEDTTACKSN THE U.S. AND
NG VOICE. ENACTINOW
AMPLIFYING PUTIN'S NARRATIVE OD
GLOBE.
FROM SHA
IS IEAR HOST PEOPLTHERE FEEL AU
ANRSSEE FOLKS G THRO
THROUGH DIFFERENT PAGES, YOU SE.
N'T SEE A LOT OF PICTURES
RE YOU AREINE.E NO
WE BY LIHIS WAR ISY N SEE
CONTINUING TO GO ON, AS THE
S PURSUING, TH'RE
E MORE OF THE IES TRICKLE IN
AND YOU SES STARTINGISED AS TO,L
THAT SAID, IT PUTSEIJING IN A
ECAUSE THE OF THISYIO STILL
APPEASE THEIR BEST-- AT T THAT'X
HAS ESID